[Music]
what do you guys think of the word
gossip it sounds cool sounds cool gossip
gossip Boston's like [ __ ] talk [ __ ] talk
I like that there's two S's in the
middle yes it reminds me of Goss like a
geese a goose goslings
yeah Ryan gossip Ryan Gosling's Frank ah
[ __ ]
what's the meaning I don't know okay I'm
just saying like is gossip a negative
thing I just put something together is
when they're saying sip' on TS cuz it's
gossip
Oh God and gossip let's go sister go
sister go sister auntie yeah never
thought about there we go sit on T and
you sit down what's the T
I don't like gossip ones just serious
when it's to Syria I don't like it
wouldn't it's um what's like what do you
call it like manipulative yeah it's
instigating yeah that's horrible but I
love roast dairy back when talking some
[ __ ] it's funny anyone actually hurt
somebody that's when I don't that's when
I cross the line bro yeah if it's like
they they slipped on a banana peel
yesterday you make fun of the mistake
yeah like [ __ ] you can't say and further
faces yeah later you go talk some [ __ ]
cuz it's so funny yeah but it doesn't
entirely hurt that other person nor does
it hurt you
true so some people are saying now
during quarantine that gossiping you
might actually be a healthier way to
cope huh a lot of gossip now yeah or
just like talking like bonding with
someone and talking [ __ ] basically yes I
talking [ __ ] in a way can be healthy
it's like something lighter and people
together then what's going on in the
world is that way yes it's bonding like
if you go to work or you go to school
alright and like you know little things
that happen throughout the day and you
share that with your significant other
you come home right I get that because I
got school what you will or like say
work or whatever that's all people talk
about and now yours at home you kind of
missed that Yeah right you know you
can't we talk about that on your public
social media or stuff like that well
like maybe with like whoever you live
with you can see I think the secrets are
fun so fun they did a study on how like
people average on just stats right of
they wired up a restaurant different
public gathering places and he wanted to
hear what people were talking about and
over 35% of the conversation was on
gossip rumors gossip did you hear about
so-and-so all that [ __ ] and I'm like
damn that's interesting yeah it's in our
human nature is what they're saying in
that we all feel closer to someone when
we're gossiping with them when we're
sharing a little secret it's like hey
I'm letting you into my world this is
what I know don't let anyone else know
and a lot of people also bond through
[ __ ] - exactly
yeah when you have a common enemy
exactly yeah well enemies strong word
but like it's like it could be a soft
version a minute a soft version yeah so
they're saying like you can take this to
an extreme and it could be very very
hurtful relating with somebody about
something whether it's like negative or
or positive you know cuz you guys both
feel the same emotion at the same time I
think most of the time gossiping by
myself do you what I do I talk [ __ ]
about myself I love talking [ __ ] about
myself I talked so much [ __ ] about
myself that TIFF tells me to stop
talking husband yeah sorry I should
probably come to you about yoni where I
heard she starts explaining what you
just told her yeah like it's like oh
wait I'm sorry no one else a gossip whip
so she hears your [ __ ] she goes you know
what Casey told me dude not only is it
funny but I was reading something about
how like any throughout history like it
was kind of used for protection like how
you survive is like and it also prevents
you from acting out like acting outside
of the out of the group's interests or
keep us in the way yeah cuz I'll be
shamed basically by the other people
people will be talking [ __ ] about you if
you're like doing something that
upsetting to the group yeah it keeps
like that creates this like a norm like
a little social economy that's like hey
you better cross the in line or else
we're gonna talk to you about you
yeah Chinese people are afraid of social
stigma like crazy though yeah I mean I
think that's one of the main reasons why
people don't become successful yes
they're so concerned of what their
aunties are gonna tell them what the
parents are gonna tell what their
siblings think what their friends think
a lot of people live in fear of what
other people think or even if you get
too famous like online you hear like
you're under scrutiny of the public and
like people are all trying to cancel
everybody right now that's gosh yeah
that's really huge like a harmful gossip
yeah I think that's when they say people
are like when you like don't give a [ __ ]
about anything that's when you like
actually evolved it's the most
liberating thing in the world yeah when
you just observe and there's because I
heard some people that gossip even more
yeah there's just [ __ ] throwing [ __ ]
at you and you're just like cool and
it's funny and then you turn it around
and you can start playing with them and
their insecurities I think that's the
funniest [ __ ] ever that's true so what's
going on here where more people are
gossiping now I'm saying like in a time
during quarantine and like how like we
just don't have a whole lot of people to
talk to and sometimes just kind of
straight to the chase of gossiping might
help was like don't hold back anymore
don't hold back yeah and like avoid the
feeling of like loneliness right yeah
you kind of giggle with somebody maybe
like where it's like like there are
toxic groups though yeah been like in
like high school or college or whatever
where people all they do is talk [ __ ]
about each other when they're not around
each other and it's like so shitty and
you're just sitting there and you're
like [ __ ] you guys man you're talking
[ __ ] about me when I'm not around I'm
not I don't want to be around you yeah
that's true like that's really I feel
like I was always the person getting
left out like you're talking [ __ ] about
you yeah like you know what I really
want to find out that people weren't my
friends until like everyone is hanging
out all the weekends or like going to
parties on my oh because I'm not
frenemies dude for your group I think
that's why I like sports might be a
healthy gossip because you get to talk
[ __ ] about people do you look at [ __ ]
traded this kind of this guy's nothing
score this many points and you get to
bond with someone else but it doesn't
really hurt anyone yeah
versus like first versus talking about
family or friends or like something cuz
sometimes you know any gossip like if I
had you're [ __ ] the Dean was
constipated the other day and somehow it
comes back to him and then dealer [ __ ]
is bar talk about my bowel movements the
gadget I go
try doing more [ __ ] to you yeah I like
talking [ __ ] in games same thing as like
spores and sex are you [ __ ] in a game
it's like a it's like a safety net like
where you're like you're not I mean the
game's over you're not enemies you're
just talking [ __ ] in the game where
you're like competitively talking [ __ ]
is great Oh think you could [ __ ] knew
it
yeah yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] kick your
ass I love mafia game was like because
you want to take this girl on a date
so and their friends they see each other
you know go over for a haircut but then
he was like dude last night something
embarrassing Ivanhoe's like oh [ __ ] like
what happened he goes two-handed like
it's so embarrassing I came to talk
about it so I thought like something
happy with the girl he was like now it's
talking [ __ ] to this team and then like
we're talking mad [ __ ] calling them
[ __ ] everything and then they beat us
and I was like it's not even real life
bro like how is that embarrassed I think
the build-up is the fun part of the
gossip it doesn't even have to be like a
big thing it's just something that's
like oh yeah what is it yeah like that
feeling of like what do you got the real
need but that was like a roller coaster
that just kept climbing and it never
dropped yeah
you just climbed off the roller
competitors were like you're the T and
stuff but what I do is - my friends are
like right before I hang up I'm like yo
yo I forgot this do you know what
happened to this person and I know no
why what and I just hang up like all the
text was like oh I think I think we got
disconnected and actually they were
responding
my god I see like Steve and I are really
talking about people but our Animal
Crossing villagers we have like a game
where we pretend we're on a reality show
with our animal crossing villagers and
they like to gossip like a animal
crossing they gossip all the [ __ ]
time about each other and they got some
about us - felt like they'll be like you
know what Steve was doing yesterday I'm
like no what was Steve doing and they're
like he was burying bells in the ground
I mean I could think of a bunch of other
things to do with bells there's a bank
on the island I'm like I know right with
a put-up [ __ ] dumbass there you go
robber or something is better if you
bury bells
money he grows on money trees so it's
actually smart investment but I like to
[ __ ] talked to with the animal crossing
ability of the bottom so there's a sense
of bonding between us like yeah what a
[ __ ] dummy and then I go bury some
bells and I hope they didn't see you
turn them all against each other no but
sometimes they get a little arguments
like there's this one guy on our island
that he always talks about working out
all the time he's like a obsessed with
working out he's the part of your island
yeah no he's not he's not the bar
because he never actually works out oh
one time one of the other villagers call
them out on it they're like if you work
out all the time where are your abs and
he's like they're not ready yet you work
out all the time like where are they
show us and he's like I'm not ready and
then they're like Nicky tell it like to
back off cuz I'm not ready and then you
can choose whether you want to say no I
think you should show us your abs or if
you're like yeah let him wait and so I'm
like naughty should show us your abs and
he's like he got so mad he stormed off
you like did like he cut Matt but you
can't piss them off for them to move out
though no yeah they ignore them to give
them a movie why does it feel like you
just hear them run away and then
obviously the kids don't you ever heard
that okay I'm a butcher this quote but
it's about gossiping right they say like
people like that talk about events
there's people that talk about people
and there's people that talk about like
big [ __ ] oh yeah Eleanor Roosevelt right
she said yeah it's in here I think I've
heard it before but something about like
gossip being like the lowest level of
conversation it is yeah yes and I I
think that it's almost like I feel like
I'm becoming dumber and dumber when I
listen to it if there's no purpose
because sometimes well a lot of the
times if you learned a lesson from a
piece of drama or something that has I
think that's good to share insight
because then you could be like oh so
that's what happened between you two and
then now you know you learn about human
tendencies through right yeah
versus you know that [ __ ] you know what
she did she was sucking this other man's
dick that's juicy [ __ ] but then you go
and then what nothing what a [ __ ] ha
yes does that [ __ ] ever happen and
you're like oh like what you're talking
about is great minds discuss ideas
average Minds discuss events small minds
discuss people yeah right but then this
one other person went to break it down
in terms of what gossip means to them
god damn why sees me so long where to go
now you understand TIFF I know I'm like
looks like I'm just trying to find these
you want to gossip but if has bigger eye
she should be able to see it faster also
highlights she highlights the things you
can highlight the website yeah she ran
up it Elaine Lou is a journalist she
said if someone were to gossip to me
about Ben Affleck and endodermis right
and there I guess newly dating what the
conversation was really talking about
was about quarantine Ian with someone
you weren't legitimate legitimately in
love with so it's about relationships
and human connection who you want to be
spending your time with so it's like
there's a deeper meaning to gossip in
the way she you know feels about it your
analysis of that situation tells me
about you what do you feel about it it's
actually the same thing that we do on JK
news every single episode it's like we
bring up a subject and then we all say
our opinions on that thing like oh that
girl's crazy I don't think that girl's
crazy I would have done the same thing
you know where the law was there's toxic
gossip yeah she was just trying to get
everybody to believe what they believe
and get them to hate the same person so
that's that [ __ ] gossip I hate so in
this article they talk about how like
when you're talking when we're talking
about survival and like the social like
survival tactics the people that gossip
in a bad way where it's only to for
their own self-interest where they only
use it to boost themselves up or to tear
other people down and it's very selfish
they'll actually get exiled from the
group so it still helps the group yet
cuz eventually they get found out and
everyone hates that person and they know
not to trust a manipulating and [ __ ]
doing this the whole time [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and also if someone spills everyone's
secrets then they know not to trust that
person
yeah
that's a big thing yeah
[Music]
[Music]